hello everyone and welcome back to game
review my name is Caleb Dendy and today
on the show we are going to be taking a
look at a game from the Magnus Carlsen
Invitational and in the Magnus Carlsen
Invitational
believe it or not Magnus Carlsen was
invited and he ended up playing against
ding Lauren
now ding of course the number three
player in the world for some time now
he's been up to number two in and out
he's dipped below number three once or
twice as well but now solidly at least
number three in the world pretty
consistently and he's a player that
Magnus Carlsen has actually historically
struggled with before so why don't we
take a look and see what happened in
this game between dink and Magnus game
started efore c5 Knight f3 bite ding
nice e6 by Magnus Bishop b5 fighting
Lauren and then I think mangoes are
having a bit of fun at his own
invitation tournament and played the
move h5 not the standard reply it to the
Rasul emo of course
Magnus before the tournament had played
a very very similar game against Peter
Svidler and believe it or not in that
blitz game he did beat Peter Svidler
with the move h5 Peter was very very
upset about it because h5 it's just not
a good move it's it's just not a good
move this should be fine that has been
played twenty-seven thousand three
hundred and forty four times in the
database time using h5 has been played
in response exactly zero times in this
data pace so not the most common move
and the reason is it just doesn't do
enough right it violates all the opening
principles you can play g6 here you can
play a six here you can play d6 here you
complain at a sixer you can play Queen
b6 but h5 doesn't do anything to help
develop your pieces so h5 and then ding
plays a slightly weird move in response
h3 so both players kind of responding in
in turn here the point of h3 is it does
take away this g4 Square from any of
black's pieces at a later date so this
is going to be a useful move for white
but perhaps this time it could have been
better spent playing a move like c3
going for an early
for or just kind of developing your
pieces one way one way or another h3
though not a terrible move by jingler n
either
and now e6 by Magnus is going back into
some slightly more normal territory and
in fact c6 is the most common move in
response or the second most common move
in response to Bishop e5 and then we're
gonna get into positions actually quite
similar to these II 6 lines except h5
and h3 are going to be included which is
you know ever so slightly strange so
back to the game we see e6 and now
ding plays c3 this is a common way of
playing against to e6 as well first and
now Knight f6 from the world champion is
actually a little bit strange generally
this Knight comes out to the e7 square
in these kinds of positions when h5
isn't on the board now that h5 is on the
board I'm not so sure it that Knight of
6 makes more sense here the movie 5 can
be played and was played in the game and
this is likely white knight f6 isn't the
most common in this opening because now
this Knight has to move again it comes
to the d5 square and now dig Lauren
actually makes a little bit of a mistake
in my opinion up to this point I think
he's been playing perfectly well but in
this position I think he got a little
bit nervous about Magnus Carlsen h5 palm
and kind of backed out of castling and
now if he did Castle here he would end
up in some very very normal positions
for this opening with the addition of
these moves age 5 and h3 and because of
that black does have this extra option
with g5 but honestly I think this should
still be fine for white there are some
clever ways for white to kind of lock
things up on the Kings side here just
one of which is for example if d4g 4 as
this pawns attacked we can actually play
the move Knight g5 and after move like
Bishop e7 h4 is a very nice way for
white to kind of take a hold on the dark
squares here and lock things up on this
Kings side instead though Diggler in
play d4 immediately and we'll see why
this is wrong
very very shortly but just for reference
I wanted to show you compare this
position where white would play d4 to
this position that we get after some
normal play so let's say instead of h5
you would see II 6 instead c3 Knight of
6 e 595 castles Bishop e7 d4 CD 4 CD 4
right you would just end up in a very
very normal position and then if black
really wants to play h5 here like he
absolutely can and h3 isn't the worst
move to ever play in response so dink
could have gone for a position exactly
like this by castling but instead he
opted for a much much more conservative
approach not castling into the kingside
and because of that I think he actually
gave away much of his advantage so back
to the game the move that he played that
I keep talking about is actually this
move indeed for and you might be
thinking well how does this give away a
lot of your advantage well the reason it
does is because you're actually just
hanging upon maybe you know he's gamba
ting upon but it is losing upon one way
or another intentional or not and the
reason for that is you cannot actually
really comfortably capture back here
because the McWeeny f5 check is going to
be devastating attacking these two
pieces at the same time if Knight c3
that just means Knight takes c3 and
you've got quite a number of problems to
to solve with the white pieces here so C
takes d4 and now ding Lauren castles and
this is why I'm slightly confused
because if Magnus wanted to go for this
position he was going to get this
position with g5 so why not castle first
I'm not so sure
I think ding Lauren should have just
Castle first in this case though now
Magnus does get to take on c3 and he is
going up in extra pawn Knight takes c3
from ding Knight takes c3 B takes c3 and
now Queen c7 and now from this position
ding Lauren I don't think is worse at
all he is just down a pawn though so
Magnus does have a little bit of
compensation here for you know his
slightly misplaced bishop here slightly
misplaced King having the extra
is quite nice for Magnus we see b6 and
now
ding Lauren plays a very very nice move
Knight g5 just directly going after this
King's weakest point as quickly as
possible and that's exactly the way you
have to play here if you have the white
pieces you just need to do something
immediate to make sure that your
advantage and development things really
felt so your opponent doesn't have time
to kind of consolidate and get all their
pieces out comfortably Magnus plays the
move Bishop d7 and now Queen f3 is the
natural reply for ding lorente going
after this pawned immediately of course
the downside is that after Knight takes
e5 ding Guren has sacrificed a second
pawn and that's okay though Queen of
four is allowed and now Magnus comes up
with a nice move Bishop d6
and it looks like black is on the verge
of having a very very safe very
comfortable position on either castling
this way or maybe even the other way so
ding Lauren had to find something
immediate here go ahead
those of you at home try and pause the
video find Magnus's killer below here
that he played
sorry team Lauren's killer blow here at
that he played in the game to put the
pressure on the world champion okay
hopefully you found it the move is of
course rook takes e5 you just remove the
defender of the f7 Square and go right
after your opponent's king you know
you've already sacrificed a couple pawns
what's another exchange you know to go
along with it
we just want to get at this King as soon
as possible absolutely cannot allow
Magnus Carlsen
to find safety now in the game Magnus
ended up playing a line that does
unfortunately just lose for him there
was one pretty wild way for black to end
up equalizing here I will show it this
is the only way black can equalize you
have to actually Castle kingside in this
position just leaving the rook here for
the moment and the downside of this is
you might think well okay the rook is
pinned I can take it at any moment but
the move Queen h4 comes on the board for
white this is the only move for whites
now if you take on a5 you're gonna get
met with Queens
age five and this is going to be just an
immediate checkmate believe it or not if
you try to move the rook out of the way
Queen takes f7 King h8 I mean back g8 h7
King f8 Bishop a3 check and there's just
no way to stop all of the threats here 9
f7 as well and black is just getting
destroyed so you cannot take that rook
on e5 unstuck untouchable after Queen h4
but black has the miracle safe here
pawn to f6 not one I would have found
either Queen takes aged five and now we
don't take the rook but rather we take
the knight and now the craziness does
not stop white can renew is the
checkmating threat with Bishop d3 but
black has exactly one move to equalize
here everything else is at least a
slight edge for white of course here
black should play the move rook takes f2
giving his king flight squares and you
know taking upon for his troubles if you
take on f2 will take on e5 somehow
material is even in black is surviving
so that is the crazy crazy crazy line
that Magnus had to train equalized here
I'm not sure any human on the planet
would be able to find that given you
know like infinite time but okay Bishop
takes e5 plate instead and now this is
just going to be very nice for jingler n
Queen takes f7 is check King over to d8
and now very nice attacking chest by
dink Bishop a3 gets more attackers into
the game bringing this Bishop out
clearing the way for the Raquel this is
using your whole army against the
opponent that's how you have to do it as
an attacker sometimes you just need to
bring all your pieces into the attack
and now Magnus really did lose the
thread here he could have tried to hold
on a little bit harder with a move like
Bishop c6 trying to challenge these
light squares get some extra defense
here and the game might continue over at
d1 can see eight you know Bishop a6 but
should be seven you can actually take
this guy and even moves like Knight
takes c6 can come on the board now the
idea being Queen takes d6 is a nasty
check but here you know Black has some
chances to hold on with a move like
Queen c64
we'll just trying desperately to defend
this king instead though magnus carlsen
played the rather you know nonchalant
move a six and you just don't have time
to play move like a six hit and tingling
rent is now completely completely
crushing the move he played is actually
the second best to move he could have in
fact actually played the move Knight
takes c6 here for king king and queen so
this night must be captured and then
after D takes c6 there's actually only
one move that wins for white but it is
very very winning it's the move Queen
takes the e6 and now the point is rook
d1 check is an unstoppable threat and it
will just be either checkmate or crazy
crazy amounts of extra material for
white instead of 96 though King played
it in the other order with rook to d1
first which is still just going to be
winning king c8 must be played for black
to step out of this pin rook takes d7
now for white is still crushing Bishop H
to check by Magnus but just king h1
Magnus tried it taking this bishop but
after it takes e7 Bishop takes e7 and it
takes you six White has a queen for two
rooks but the the black king is just
absolutely just devastated here on the
c8 square Bishop e5 is played and then
begin the very very funny attacking
moves for white here of course you want
to get at this King how can you get it
this King well I don't know this rook is
in the way so what is ding the Wren do
he just blocks off this truck plays
Bishop f8 and it's the best move really
really fun attacking stuff from ding
here just interfering with this Dirk's
defense of the King Bishop c6 now for
Magnus tries to hold on to the e8 square
but just a bishop takes g7 this Bishop
steps back to d6 note if you take this
guy you get checkmated so Bishop d6
instead and now we just take an extra
rook for our troubles rook to takes a 2
now we have a square on the back rank so
Queen g8 check King d7 and then of
course the last move of the game the
crushing 9 f8 checkmate
not checkmate sorry but all pieces to
the back rank net if a check and this
rook is is falling as well pretty fun
stuff from dinger and ending up with all
his pieces on the back rank just
destroying world champion Magnus Carlsen
and while ding didn't directly refute
this move h5 out of the opening from
Magnus the way he played was really
really fun really creative really
attacking chess so hopefully you guys
enjoyed this game that's all for me here
today on game review my name is Caleb
Denby and I will see you next time